[Musica]
[Applauso]
che vorrei condividere con lei la grande
stima che nutro nei riguardi di a
leggere la mia figlia primogenita
dopo di lei ci sono due stabili di una
sorellina di 9 anni e un piccoletto di
tre e con loro mi dà davvero una grande
mano se quella sorella di mezzo nei
compiti e nelle attività
extrascolastiche dovendo io badare al
piccoletto devo dire che invita anche un
grosso contributo in casa con i mestieri
è iscritta al secondo anno delle
superiori dove frequenta da studentessa
diligente la seconda liceo e insomma
devo proprio dire che si tratta di una
ragazza giudiziosa ed educatissima
volevo portare la mia testimonianza di
madre orgogliosa e soddisfatta il
martedì tendo un piccolo format di volte
risposta su instagram dove mi faccio
carico delle questioni che i genitori
che mi seguono mi sollevano ecco che
meraviglia questo messaggio non ricevo
moltissimi di questo tenore
mamme e papà che mi raccontano dei loro
figli adolescenti bravissimi in gamba
affettuosi con cui hanno nelle relazioni
estremamente soddisfacenti anche con i
loro nonni e così i ragazzi che hanno
con loro rapporti scambievoli
arricchenti ragazzi impegnati che fanno
sport che fanno volontariato ma che
amano anche stare in casa nel focolare
del magari sabato sera impastano la
pizza da mangiarsi tutti insieme prima
di un bel feeling sul divano
ebbene sì adolescente di così non solo
esistono ma ormai non sono più
l'eccezione i loro genitori dovrebbero
essere stati più o meno
pazzini quando nel 1970 stessa band si
chiamavano i vicini di casa
suona con un pezzo intitolato 15 anni
sta se l'hanno mai sentito se l'hanno
scortato se gli sta avvenendo in questo
momento potrebbe anche cantar velo ma
facciamo un velocità e basta la cantava
della storia d'amore di questi due
quindicenni per l'appunto che si dà
appuntamento fuori da scuola alla
fermata del tram tram sul quale
scandalizzarono il sacerdote con cui
viaggiavano perché limona vano tutto il
tempo fumavano e il pomeriggio con la
scusa di studiare geografia ascoltavano
i giradischi correndo certi rischi
insomma non è un caso che poi ritornello
cantasse manti come due cavalli io e te
perché vedete 15 anni non è mai stato
solo un numero
un dato all'ufficio anagrafe di qualche
comune 15 anni è sempre stato sinonimo
di caos un anatema da lanciare ai
genitori che vedevano arrivare a delle
scelte dei loro figli
la guardavano all'inizio con sospetto e
poi con terrore crescente salendo del
pezzo che avrebbero pagato con mora
interessi
anche loro da figli avevano fatto ai
loro genitori casavola sceglierà sempre
avuto dei significati tra musica t a più
livelli
intanto un faust relazionale fatto di
porte sbattute strette silenzi ma poi
alcun gauss fisico visibile e misurabile
estetico il caos dei corpi corpi
manipolarti tatuati additati oltraggiati
il caos dei luoghi stanze da bagno e
trattate come succursali di industrie
belliche dovrebbe tra appunto l'atomica
o cane da letto insidiose come le case
dell'orrore al luna park buy e irta di
ostacoli dentro le quali un certo punto
può stabilire di non entrarci del tutto
o entrarci ma con gli artificieri per
riportare ordine in mezzo al caos di
calze mutande scarpe puzzolenti cibo
mezzo mangiato carapace vestiti debiti
soprattutto ebbene fino più o meno
quindici anni fa dalla fine
dell'ottocento avrà quindici anni voleva
dire questa roba qui cioè intanto avere
figli amici che i due non avevano idea
che fossero poi offre tu stesso un tizio
di cui tuoi
i posti non avere i social network su
cui essere continuamente geolocalizzati
quindi reperibili e poi andare in una
scuola dove non c era registra
elettronico che denuncia sta in tempo
reale che viene presentato a lezione
insomma quella che ritengo i genitori
mancano le informazioni di base che una
madre e un padre ha diritto di avere
dov'era il figlio con chi è a fare cosa
a la questione cantata è oggi le cose
non stanno più in questi vermi e non
come adulti abbiamo gli strumenti di
controllo che non esitiamo a giara e
facciamo bene perché ci lasciano
tranquilli perché se possiamo
sorvegliare i nostri figli
possiamo impensati possiamo usa per aver
paura possiamo non chiederci se siamo
dei genitori inadeguati possiamo tornare
ad occuparci di altre nostre questioni
adulte lavoro i soldi i nostri genitori
invecchiato che stanno invecchiando cioè
far estinguere della licenza per noi è
stata una questione di wojtyla
abbiamo dovuto e siamo stati molto in
gamba cioè diamoci una pacca sulla
spalla perché da adulti genitori
educatori docenti
siamo stati davvero molto bravi a
trasformare i nostri figli in amici
colleghi
pari grado e compagno di squadra
siamo la prima generazione di genitori
di sempre che dialogo con gli obiettivi
non solo ci parlano ma ci ascoltano ci
capita di portare loro le nostre
preoccupazioni e loro ci danno dei
consigli vedete una missione contingente
con il mio mestiere mi riguarda da
vicino io faccio la psicoterapeuta e
dell'adolescenza
ormai i genitori non importano più i
figli da raddrizzare scavezzacollo
trasgressivi che non sanno più da che
parte prendere gli abbiamo tolto
l'adolescenza dalla testa di gara
abbiamo fatto passare sono guariti
sì certo poi stragrande maggioranza di
orario non siano a quella vita è colpa
nostra
c'è quella evidentemente colpa della
prova di matematica che non vuole fare
le interrogazioni programmate e si sarà
la più esigente dell'istituto sì è vero
ci sono anche quelli che digiunano o e
poi vomitano ma quello è colpa della
nostra società dell'immagine
superficiale e nichilista narcisista ci
vuole tutti uguali bene madrid successo
sì sì ci sono anche quelli che finiscono
per essere vittima di episodi di
cyberbullismo anche gravi ma quelle
colmati stramaledetti social network
su questo numero ci siamo iscritti è ci
siamo iscritti perché abbiamo allenato
degli stili di vista inoltre hanno le
richieste di amicizia non ce lo
accettano
quindi possiamo controllare cosa postano
con chi interagiscono e siccome questa
loro seguiamo anche i loro compagni di
classe e i loro amici
possiamo davvero dire di essere genitori
attenti bravi lui mi dà come quelli che
non stavano dovere un figlio come chi sa
fare cosa perché poi questi qui questi
altri ragazzi li vedi in giro è allora
vestiti in maniera improbabile in
solenne fissi mi che pioli in bocca
parole ignominiose più fanno in modo di
pronunciarla ad alta voce perché
vogliono che le senti vogliono essere
molesti vogliono che tu te ne accorga
ragazzi che non voglia di fare niente
questo è ovvio perché sono sempre in
giro cerca non hanno in mente di
studiare lo smartphone con gli orsi i
videogames quelli sì ragazzi che non
sanno cosa sia il rispetto che non sa
che cosa sia l'impegno ragazzi che non
ti rivolgono la parola significa di una
domanda non rispondono se rispondono
buffoni piano ma sai quando le senti
quando hanno da chiederti qual cosa
quando hanno qualcuna delle loro
richieste assurde che tu poi qualche
volta accondiscenza e cerchi devi
portargli un po dalla tua parte
immigrati non sono mai contenti lo di
basta mai sempre concluso ragazzi a cui
magari trovi nelle tasche la cellino le
cartine che rubano
re telefoniche ai loro genitori che
comunque gli stessi genitori ci pigliano
cioè fujiyama t d amore incondizionato
fino a quel momento gli hai dato tutto e
pare che a un certo momento si voltino
le spalle non ti vogliano più belli sono
i figli generatori del caos in famiglia
qualcuno se ne vede ancora in giro ma
signori manteniamoci lungo un fronte
compatto
dobbiamo far sparire dalla circolazione
anche questi ultimi esemplari perché non
sono persone di cui fidarsi
è gente che non rinuncia alla propria
vita per semplificare quella dei suoi
genitori e gente mutaforma in continuo
cambiamento in evoluzione non sai cosa
aspettarti da loro perché non le
riconosce vi sono differenti da un
minuto con l'altro hanno dismesso la
pelliccia morbida dell'infanzia quella
programmata per farsi le coccole e lungo
tutto il perimetro del loro corpo sono
ricoperti di alcune che ritraggono solo
se devono incontrare gli amici di ma
quando si tratta della mamma e del papà
li usano per raggiungere per fare male
ragazzi che dopo 13 14 15 anni dalla
loro nascita si trovano a campare un
secondo cordone non più americano
emozionale sembrano senza regole senza
coscienza senza rispetto
perché l'unico contratto che sono
disposti a deliberare e quello che hanno
stipulato quella novità
e così imparano ad odiarli e farsi
odiare esattamente quella stessa
violenza con cui avevano amato la mamma
e papà li tradiscono perché
l'alternativa è tradire se stessi lì
deludono cominciando ad anteporre i loro
bisogni evolutivi a quelli della loro
famiglia e mentre fanno tutto questo
cioè mentre fanno soffrire le loro mamme
e papà non mollano niente non possono
mai dismettere il loro personaggio del
figlio che genere perché il loro ruolo
di statista non ammette pause e così
anche se ci sono dei giovedì sera in cui
dopo un litigio furente avrebbero
tentazione di tornare di oggi e ancor
paul arsi nel grembo della madre che non
facevano da piccole che dirle d'arma
fare così dal fare il fois per diventare
grande cosa credito non me lo
risparmierà in ritiro tutto questo
cinema o ai padri sipa vero forse io
starò a tratti nella vita un po meglio
di come nella vita
ma cosa credete che per me sia davvero
facile odiare che in realtà non
vorrebbero dirlo sono tentativi ma non
posso non possono mai calare la loro
mascheratura e iniquità
perché vedete la nostra natura è il caos
l'ordine è la cultura che poi diventiamo
soprano nel caos è la condizione
primigenia veniamo al mondo squarciando
il corpo della madre non lo chiameremo
forse caos
cresciamo attraverso strappi e linee
spezzate la vita stessa è caos allo
stato puro che il genio ci illudiamo di
direzionare verso dove come vorremmo noi
che andasse ma le emozioni sono di casa
i sentimenti caos i colpi di fortuna
calcio causa anche quelli le famiglie
le famiglie sono luoghi caotici di gente
che si mette insieme promettendosi che
sarà per sempre promessa che i figli
adolescenti smettono di mantenere ma
guardate che io lo so lo so che fa paura
a me fa paura ai miei pazienti sopra un
tra le persone con cui interloquisco mi
dicono che fa paura basta guardarci tore
perché abbiamo paura
abbiamo paura io lo so che è un figlio
che obbedisce un figlio bravo che fa
quello che dici tu che non ti dà
problemi che ti fa fare bella figura che
ti illude di aver fatto un buon lavoro
con lui lo so quello che non so essa il
caso di essere orgogliosi di loro come
la mamma di cui sopra perché in realtà
vedete sono dei marchi che abdicano al
loro caos perché hanno capito che noi
non saremo come affrontarlo non sapremmo
cosa farcene
e così il loro caos si scontrano i
nostri limiti e le nostre incompetenza
quel punto vantini reti spa dove e loro
rinunciano ad aggiungere il loro nome
lungo la lista delle preoccupazioni page
abili ci sembrano figli maturi già
cresciuti sono farfalle nell'ambra non
succede loro niente non evolvono non
corrono nessun rischio è vero certo se
studio degli spiriti diventare di non
diventare a nessuno sono il figlio di
tuo padre e tua madre di non diventare
che spesso di non diventare al unito
sono eroici nel loro tentativo di
addomesticare skies fanno talmente tanti
sforzi e tanti di loro scollinati
vent'anni poi non fanno più niente
hanno compiuto l'impresa di mantenere
l'ordine colomo e di gusto l'acqua
cos'altro di vita dice suoi come sale in
giorno ha iscritto il giovane holden e
chiaro che poi ti ritiri a vita privata
nei boschi cioè ai redatto la tua opera
prima
sai perfettamente che sarà la più grande
di sempre cos'altro ci si deve aspettare
del tempo
ecco i figli senza caos quando diventano
un po più grandi me li raccontano così
dottoressa come faccio da diventare mia
figlia ha cantato due sa quel tanto da
farli adesso non sa che fare se
continuare a studiare e lavorare e cosa
nell'uno caso o nell'altro perché io non
so come parlarne non ci ha mai dato di
questi problemi è uscita vincente dalla
maturità dottoressa come parlo mio
figlio come gli faccio capire che stava
andando via la sua vita 24 anni la pasta
sul divano era la playstation
la ragazza ha lasciato per questo io mio
marito siamo dispiaciuti perché era
talmente una brava ragazza che preferiva
mandarla in giro per casa
non riesco più a parlar di sé ligure ci
siamo sempre detti tutto vedete non sono
circa
io so perfettamente che innamorarsi del
caos è il sentimento dei paesi ma temo
che l'alternativa detestarlo
allontanarlo irregimentare o addirittura
invece sia il gesto degli assassini
degli attentatori di futuro di coloro
che non sanno che li chiamavo su una
persona è il segnale che le stia
succedendo qualcosa è come la linea fas
tagliata sul monitor che dice che c'è
ancora vita che c'è ancora un cuore che
batte il caos e il disordine della
materia prima della nascita del cosmo e
quella prima che precede la soluzione il
genio le pmi
guardateli caos non so se lo sapete
nella sua pressione etimologica
originaria non voleva mica abbiamo il
casino che poi gli abbiamo attribuito
noi dalla greco antico causa si riferiva
alle fenditure agli squarci all'affaccio
sui grandi spazi aperti
allora l'invito che vi faccio coraggioso
ammetto e di augurarvi di avere a che
fare con dei figli alle prese con il
loro calcio e prima di avere paura per
loro esserne contenti
immaginandoli affacciati sulla loro vita
destinati al loro futuro
[Applauso]